all right sasha yes
sasha where do you grew up where are you
from originally um originally i was born
in south sudan
and um i grew up in minneapolis um i
came to america in 2004
so i grew up in minneapolis so you came
to america what age five five years old
yes
and you had both your parents um my mom
and my stepdad
and how was your childhood um well
growing up
um it was very different with the
culture and things like that when i came
to america
neither one of me or my parents
understood english or anything like that
so it was very different to learn to
adapt to the american culture and things
like that
but i got it quick i understood it
and growing up it was a girl in a kind
of an abusive home
my stepfather was abusive towards my
mother
and i um physically verbally
emotionally all that so eventually my
mom got tired of that
and ended up going to a shelter a better
woman shelter
and from there my mom got on her feet
was working finding a job and was able
to find
her own place for us and while i was
while growing up my mom had a boyfriend
and during the period of time he was
living with us he
sexually assaulted me on multiple
occasions
so when i was eight years old i had my
virginity taken away from me
so that started messing with my head and
so i started looking at life at a very
different
point of view and looking at myself at a
different point of view and
lowering myself to a different standard
than other kids around me
how do you think it affected you it made
you feel less worried
um less worthy it made me feel like
like what am i wasn't well like i'm not
nothing like if a grown man doesn't have
any respect
on a child then like what like what am i
here for you know i'm not really worth
nothing
um who can protect me if an adult can't
protect me
like i'm just out here lost in the world
so
yeah did you feel like that played a
role in you ending up working figaro's
right now most definitely because it's
like
if at that age people are sleeping with
me why not you know put a price on it
why not you know
i'm not going to be nothing if that's
all men look at me as an objective
growing up without a father and just
having a mother
i never really had a perfect male
role model in my life that you know
showed me that what a male is how
supposed to
treat a woman respect a woman i've never
seen it in my mom's relationships
or in any relationships that i've had
personally growing up
so it's very hard for me to trust a man
or even allow a man to get that close to
me because
i always think it's some [ __ ] so do
you recall your
your very first time of doing this um
yes i was about
16 a friend had actually introduced me
into a game
and she didn't really like say nothing
much of it like you know
we're just gonna go in here and you know
just talk to this guy and you know
she's gonna give you this or for
whatever and that was that and from then
on i just
went with it and i was already running
away from home and
didn't really have a stable home and
things like that so it's like
i was out in the streets anyways funding
for myself so why not i need money i
need food i need shelter i need clothes
things like that
all the necessities so why not
have you had bad experiences out there
have you had bad experiences with
working distribution um
yeah um i ran into a couple
people that were not you know
i've just had people try to hurt me
try to kidnap me things like that um
yeah have you been arrested before
yes yeah i went to jail
um actually when i started coming out
working in l.a was the first time i went
to jail for
prostitution and um yeah that was
that was not great i didn't like that
were you doing this in minneapolis as
well yeah but minneapolis we don't have
streets
everything is online or on the internet
and things like that
or girls are working in the clubs but
minneapolis we don't have
no streets or nothing like that where
girls can just go working and things
how much money were you making tonight
no um
varies depending on if it's a school
night it could be seven
to a thousand are you saving money
do i save money yes you do yeah i wanna
i'm i'm i wanna
start modeling i wanna i wanna
be an entrepreneur um
and help my start my own business i
wanna help people i wanna
like just like i don't know help girls
young teens anybody just get out this
situation of homelessness
um any struggles you know to open doors
because
i know how it is growing up as a young
youth being homeless being out in the
streets
not having nowhere to go things like
that and that without you know that
without having a home or things like
that it's like you're just out here
doing whatever and
kids get into gang banging kids get into
prostitution
kids get into robbing stealing all those
type of things and it's just like
i want to be able to help my people save
them from that before they get to that
route
that's great does your family know that
you do this
yeah what are they saying my mother does
but
i mean what can she really say she could
just
pray and hope that i mean with the
childhood
abuse that you went through and then
the family you had you almost led you
down this path right
yeah not really a lot of support so
does it get you down sometimes you get
depressed yeah
yeah like going back to my room
and just sometimes you just feel alone
you know
but it's like you just gotta
keep going like you know what your
purpose is so
can't stop but yeah it gets depressing
yeah it gets
it gets too much at one time it gets
overwhelming but
i mean that much
you gotta survive you gotta figure it
out you gotta make it one way or another
mm-hmm and you have no kids you're young
right
i have a three-year-old son oh you do
mm-hmm how old are you
i'm 21. 21. are you raising your son
yeah he's about my mom with my mom right
now
so i'm going back to minnesota on friday
his birthday is on the 17th of this
month so he's back in minnesota
mm-hmm he's not here no i i come i fly
out here to work and then i go back to
minnesota go back so you still
you still live in minneapolis
do you feel like you have a little bit
of a victim mentality because of the
things that happened to you
no because i don't i don't let that hold
me back
you can climb you can rise above it yeah
because
if i sit and play a victim just
be my own pity and stuff like that i'm
not gonna move nowhere i'm gonna be
stuck
so i try to make these as a stepping
stone like okay
you know what i'm saying like i'm not
the only one everybody faces things in
life but it's up to us to you know make
a difference on if
how we want our lives to go i'm the only
one that can make a difference you know
the things that happen to me it happened
but
have you considered uh talking to a
therapist about
yeah i've had therapy you've had was
that helpful
yeah it did
it was good but
therapy can only do so much at the end
of the day it it all falls back on the
person
on how they want to move on and how
they're gonna
take what you know take these
whatever it is that comes to them and
you know turn it around how they're
playing it
does the fast money of the street become
addictive you think
um no because
well for me personally it's not because
i would i would rather have
a nine to five job and know that i have
consistent income coming
i have a reliable you know i'm i'm
gonna make it to work safely and i'm
gonna make it back home safely whereas
this
this is the wrist this is the every
night you go outside you're taking
chances going in these clients cars you
don't know what could happen
going with these people to people's
houses it's just a lot of risk
and going to jail that's not it's not
worth it especially
yeah it's not worth it when it comes
down to when everything comes down to it
the money is fun
yup you can it's good money whatever you
can go
do this you know girls like to go get
their hairs on trips whatever whatever
whatever but
when it's all said and over with how do
you really feel like
money can't buy happiness it can't
and if you're not happy then it's not
for nothing
what is it what are you doing it for
what's the purpose that
can't be a hoe forever at the end of the
day we're gonna get old saggy and
it's gonna be another little girl turn
18 and come out here and just
you know so it's like what's your
purpose
money is good but what's the purpose
what are you doing this for why are you
out here
because every day you're taking a risk
and giving yourself to
somebody like
do you feel like doing this to generate
money is uh
affected the way you see men um
yeah a little bit i mean i've always had
my guard up since i was a child so
um relationships with men it
it's right now i think it's not really
an appropriate time for me
to even try to consider myself being
with anybody like that because
i have to get myself fully together and
i have a child that i'm raising
so those two are my number two
priorities
and i can't give myself to somebody
without taking care of myself first
have you met a male figure who is a
stand-up guy who
who isn't what i would be interested in
well not necessarily that you're
interested in but
maybe you could be interested or maybe
he's not but not right now i haven't
have you ever met anybody who's like a
guy that you respect and
see that his motives are pure and stuff
like that yeah
yeah business just probably not from eat
why not for you um i don't know i think
i don't know
i guess i just don't know what i want
yet that's probably what i'm telling
myself
you have to be able to accept a guy like
that before you yeah and that's what i'm
saying i just still
you're still struggling with that yeah
well myself not necessarily the other
person
yeah and you're 24 years old 21 21 i'm
sorry even younger
you've got a long way to go and yeah so
you're still a kid
pretty much yeah
do you have any dreams of where you'd
like to be in in your future
um in my future you mentioned like
helping others
hopefully yeah with my entrepreneurial
business if i if i'm
start modeling i hope i see myself just
giving back to my community in
minneapolis i see myself helping
helping people i see myself going back
to africa
with my family i just
see myself just being a mother taking
care of my son
and being at home with him and giving
him my time and my energy
do you think the the way that your
parents
raised you helps you or hurts you in
terms of the way you're
raising your child it helps
because i learned a lot of great
qualities for my mom
because like i said my mom came from
another foreign country
and was able to make it and did not use
non-skill she's a nurse right now she
has her own place
like everything like that so she's
always prospered through all everything
like she's never let nothing
she's never sat and played the victim
basically like
she's been abused a lot of stuff you
know she doesn't have no but it's just
me and her
in america we don't my grandma her
siblings everybody's still back in
africa
so she she's a very strong woman and
that's the
greatest quality like that i'm a carry
over to my child and that's why
i haven't stopped and that's why i
haven't used this as an excuse because
my mom didn't stop so i know it's
something greater for me in this world
too
so i'm gonna keep going till i get it
all right sasha sasha thank you so much
for talking with me
good luck with your future and your son
thank you
let me ask you one more question i guess
i can edit these together okay
um uh do you use drugs at all
no you stay away from all that yeah i'll
drink
occasionally but i tried to or not
do you have to be drunk to do this
sometimes no no
no i just like i like to like you know
like get in my mouth like you know like
just a little drink or whatever but
i'm not i tried to because at the end of
the day you have to be
you have to be aware of your
surroundings you have to be aware of
everything that's going on so if you're
high or even drunk
and something happens you know and it's
a lot of situations where girls are
intoxicated
and get robbed or get raped or get in
anything like
and that's scary do you use your
intuition with the guys you pick up yeah
sometimes you just say this one feels
bad i do a lot
because sometimes people be like girl
why you eating and go
because i just feel it like sometimes
that's why i say the money's not worth
it sometimes like sometimes you just
feel like
he's not really this might be a sticky
situation
it's okay to just leave that little
money right there
so yeah that's for the most part that's
where i go by because i've been in a lot
of situations where
it may seem like it's good he may have a
nice car
the best money but then his attitude is
disgusting
and now i'm [ __ ] up yeah
all right thank you so much
you